der Krieg hat erhebliche Auswirkungen
auf die Frage unserer Energieversorgung
und vielleicht haben Sie es schon an der
Tankstelle gemerkt die Preise gehen nach
oben ja und während wir darüber
diskutieren sollten wir die Einfuhr von
russischen Öl und Gas stoppen und Putin
damit weiter sanktionieren spricht Putin
seinerseits die Drohung schon aus
erwarnt vor einem gaslieferstopp die
Energieminister der Bundesländer beraten
heute jetzt schon über steigende Preise
und wie wir unabhängiger werden können
mehr dazu jetzt von Alexander Gebhardt
ein Liter Diesel für mehr als zwei Euro
die Kraftstoffpreise in Deutschland
steigen der Krieg die
lieferunsicherheiten und die große
Nachfrage ein Ausstieg jetzt aus dem Öl
und Gasgeschäft mit Russland klares Nein
aus Deutschland die Versorgung Europas
mit Energie für die Wärmeerzeugung für
die Mobilität die Stromversorgung und
für die Industrie kann im Moment nicht
anders gesichert werden sie ist daher
von essentieller Bedeutung für die
Daseinsvorsorge und das tägliche Leben
unser Bürgerinnen und Bürger
Downing Street London hier geht es um
das schnellstmögliche aus für russisches
Öl und Gas der niederländische
Ministerpräsident bei premier Johnson
Großbritannien könne schnell aussteigen
sagt Johnson
andere Länder können das auch was wir
aber erreichen müssen ist dass wir uns
alle in die gleiche Richtung bewegen und
dass wir diese Bewegung schneller machen
um Tempo und Energie geht es auch in
Brüssel Ministerpräsident Trages Italien
hängt von öde und Gas aus Russland ab
dragebelein schnelles Ende dieser
Abhängigkeit die EU sucht Wege für ihre
Mitgliedsländer
die Kommission wird dazu Dienst nach
Vorschläge machen ein Punkt ist die
Lieferungen weg von Russland auf andere
verlässliche Versorger zu verteilen
da geht es vor allem um flüssig und
pipeline-
doch wie schnell würde das gehen der
Kreml reagiert am späten Abend auf die
europäischen Überlegungen mit der
Drohung die Gasversorgung nach
Deutschland und Europa durch die Leitung
Nord Stream 1 in der Ostsee zu
unterbrechen
sprechen wir dazu mit unserem
Korrespondenten zuständig für Russland
Axel Sturm guten Morgen
guten Morgen Axel wir haben jetzt gerade
im Stück gehört Putin droht also mit dem
Stopp von Gaslieferungen nach
Deutschland aber er verdient ja mit
diesem Export auch sein Geld also wie
ernst müssen wir diese Drogen nehmen
naja ich denke dass wir im Kontext des
aktuellen Kriegsverlaufes eigentlich
jede Drogen aus dem Kreml ernst nehmen
müssen die Situation war gestern so dass
der stellvertretende russische
Regierungschef Alexander Nowak vor die
Kameras getreten ist im russischen
Staatsfernsehen und sozusagen davon
gesprochen hat dass man als Reaktion auf
die Stilllegung von nordstream 2 oder
das verschleppte Verfahren von
nordstream 2 man durchaus darüber
nachdenken könnte Nord Stream 1 zu
blockieren kein Gas mehr nach Europa zu
liefern aber man muss dabei auch sehen
dass das natürlich auch Russland sehr
hart treffen würde es würde Deutschland
treffen und es würde unsere Preise in
die Höhe treiben es würde unsere
verarbeitende Industrie natürlich
treffen aber Russland verdient viele
Hunderte von Millionen Dollar an Geld
mit diesen energietransporten und die
Frage ob sich die Russische Föderation
das momentan leisten kann und will die
steht in den Sternen
Axel ein weiteres wichtiges Thema die
Berichterstattung und die
Meinungsfreiheit in Russland die ja
erheblich eingestrengt sind hier nochmal
Bilder von man kann es nicht anders
sagen mutigen Menschen die trotzdem
offen protestieren und auch festgenommen
werden wie geht es der russischen
Bevölkerung zum einen damit zum anderen
aber auch wie geht es Ihnen mit den
Sanktionen des Westens denn die sind ja
bald zu spüren zum Beispiel auch was den
Zahlungsverkehr angeht
ja der
Zahlungsverkehr ist betroffen erst vor
wenigen Tagen haben wir die großen
Kreditkartenfirmen Mastercard und Visa
angekündigt dass sie ihre
Dienstleistungen in der Russischen
Föderation nicht mehr anbieten werden
aber die Menschen in der Russischen
Föderation sind diejenigen die am
meisten unter den Sanktionen leiden
werden es wird darauf hinauslaufen dass
vermutlich Produkte fehlen werden das
Supermarktregale möglicherweise nicht
mehr so gefüllt sind wie sie das gewöhnt
sind es gab auch schon vor einigen Tagen
die ersten Meldungen von Supermärkten in
Moskau die damit beginnen die
abzugebende Menge an Produkten zu
rationieren also man kann nicht mehr
unbegrenzt viele Produkte kaufen das
alles sind Auswirkungen der doch sehr
breiten westlichen Sanktionen und die
werden die Menschen in Russland
sicherlich zu spüren bekommen
Einschätzungen aktuell an diesem Morgen
von unserem kursmenten Axel Sturm
dankeschön
und während Russland droht den Gashahn
abzudrehen sind bereits jetzt schon die
Auswirkungen in der westlichen
Sanktionen im Land selbst spürbar da
Rubel der befindet sich in freien Fall
und die Kreditwürdigkeit ist praktisch
neu und die USA könnten nun die
Daumenschrauben weiter anziehen viele
Kongressmitglieder wollen einen
import-stopp von russischer Energie wir
haben heute früh mit unserem Washington
Korrespondenten el MRT Wissen darüber
gesprochen
[Musik]
die Einigkeit ist hier groß und zwar so
groß dass es heute vielleicht schon ein
Gesetz geben könnte über den Stopp der
Energielieferungen vor allen Dingen der
Öllieferungen aus Russland das könnte
der Kongress beschließen der Präsident
müsste es nur unterschreiben ob er das
tut hängt eben davon ab ob tatsächlich
Ersatz gefunden wird es gibt ein gutes
Signal nämlich das Venezuela der
Präsident Maduro signalisiert hat er
könnte sich schon vorstellen mehr Öl zu
liefern um die Welt zu stabilisieren wie
er sagt ein gutes Signal